psa reste une ville qui est pas très
saine non plus qu'ils restent eau
polluée mais toulouse comme ça reste
beaucoup plus grand et qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de monde je trouve
[Musique]
vous pensez quoi de l'arrivée des
trottinettes à toulouse mais j'aime pas
parce que après les jeux n'avaient pas
conduit la trottinette est aussi ça ça
fait encore peur des pollutions pour
l'électricité
je viens de séville espagne en ont tous
beaucoup le vélo mais dans le
centre-ville là trottinent et c'est
maintenant un peu nouveau aussi comme
dans leur cité europe et
ça et vos soeurs ils en pensent quoi
donc à vos soeurs elle en pense pas que
c'est grâce à ma place
[Applaudissements]
mais on est et las ketchup et m
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
pollution à toulouse écoutez je pense
pas que toulouse soit aussi peuplé que
aussi pollué que ça maintenant il faut
demander aux toulousains qui habite
toute l'année ici
moi je viens ici comment plaisir une
fois par semaine à peu près où vous
habitez ou à la base
j'habite dans un petit village du lot
qui s'appelle montcuq et vos frères et
ce but là bas aussi
j'ai pas de frère oui tout à fait on
habite là-bas si lyon n'est plus là où
on a grandi à montcuq coiffé ou je tiens
à dire à tous les gens qui s'amusent à
dire montcuq c'est pas très drôle c'est
montcuq mexique
tout le monde est bienvenu à montcuq
montcuq monkey pas excusé what is your
opinion à base de pollution à toulouse
[Musique]
si steph y assister
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on est des roses mais qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la pollution à toulouse la
pollution à toulouse on la sent beaucoup
surtout dans l'air vous n'êtes béziers
ou une différence avec béziers je vois
une différence avec béziers parce que
business ça reste une ville qui est pas
très saine non plus qu'ils restent eau
polluée mais toulouse comme ça reste
beaucoup plus grand et qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de monde je trouve que c'est quand
même une ville qui est plus pollué et
elle en pense quoi vos soeurs mes soeurs
alors elles sont plutôt d'accord avec
moi alors ça on est 100 % d'accord
d'accord à 100%
elle a raison sur toute la ligne ça je
peux vous dire que on est d'accord à
100% même si on sait pas ce qu'elle a
dit qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
pollution à toulouse on la sent mais
pour l'instant c'est tout mais on on
ressent quand même que c'est pas
forcément un air très sincère très
propre contrairement à ici c est
pourtant si on est vraiment à 200 mètres
d'une dune d'une avenue une avenue
automobile mais ici on sent déjà quand
même un peu mieux au final
bon il ya des endroits où on le ressent
plus et d'autres moins terne et qu'est
ce qu'on veut c'est de l'arrivée des
trottinettes à toulouse sincèrement pour
les trottinettes écologiquement parlant
je sais pas trop ces bons selectric
forcément la consommation électrique la
fabrication tout ça mais c'est plus je
pense au niveau des utilisateurs où il
ya quand même un problème et il en pense
quoi votre frère moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord quoi les trottinettes c'est
dangereux on peut foncer sur les gens
c'est quasiment une énorme en une arme
mortelle quoi je pense que tous nos
frères sont d'accord on est tous pareils
totalement d'accord
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'être très haut niveau ça
merci c'est mon phone ou la chine quels
conseils vous auriez à donner aux gens
pour améliorer la qualité de l'air à
toulouse de l'air alors là je ne sais
pas moi une voiture je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de transport en commun envoyé
on a pris les transports en commun pour
aller me rappelle plus comment ça
s'appelle laurent c'est ça la prune
voilà et donc je trouve qu'il y en a
beaucoup à y aller a les bus si elle
le tram ni à la mettrons et ils ont
pensé quoi vos frères vos frères vos
frères en pense quoi
j'ai pas peur des bâtons dans les
accords à la casquette 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]